federal agents encountered more than a
quarter million illegal aliens at the
border last month
251 487 to be exact the highest number
ever recorded in U.S history and that is
just the number that were detected many
people are blaming Democrats who opened
the Border some are blaming the squishes
who let the Democrats get away with it
but the Democrats are blaming the
Republicans for noticing the problem
according to one Biden Administration
official quote of course the numbers
will be higher when Republican elected
officials like Smugglers falsely
proclaim the border is open because of a
court order to lift title 42 in other
words the border is open not because the
Democrats opened it but because the
Republicans pointed out that it's open
this is a weird sort of quantum politics
in which observing the political problem
supposedly creates the political problem
in the first place